hello and welcome to the bio conference
live webinar on heavy light chain
combination assays what laboratories
should know about em protein detection
our speaker today is dr. Richard O'Hara
dr. O'Hara received a baccalaureate
degree in biology from the University of
Texas at Austin after working as a
research associate for a few years he
entered the immunology graduate program
at the University of Texas Southwestern
Medical School dr. O'Hara spent the
final two years of his graduate training
at Dalhousie University in Halifax Nova
Scotia working with the group that
established the first liver transplant
program in the region following his
graduate training he entered a
postdoctoral training program at Harvard
Medical School working on mechanisms of
t-cell mediated immune regulation he
entered the pharmaceutical industry
joining genetics Institute as a research
scientist in 1988 his work on cytokine
biology led to the development of two
new therapeutic drugs and several US
patents in hematology and oncology later
work in the role of co-stimulation and
graft rejection and autoimmunity led to
the development of several other drug
candidates in 2007 after more than 20
years of research in the fields of
autoimmunity and transplantation he
joined the binding site as senior
director of scientific affairs in his
role of binding site dr. O'Hara has
presented extensively at major US
academic medical centers on the
characterization of monoclonal proteins
and patients with multiple myeloma and
other plasma cell discourages before it
turn it over to dr. O'Hara I want to
cover a few logistics during the
presentation you have the ability to
type questions into the Q&A box located
in the lower left hand of your screen
after his presentation dr. O'Hara will
have time to answer the questions dr.
O'Hara I will now turn it over to you
Thank You Maureen for that introduction
and thanks to everybody for joining the
broadcast today what I wanted to talk
about or some new tools in the toolkit
that the laboratory can use when
detecting monoclonal proteins from
diseases such as multiple myeloma and
other plasma cell disgraces Before we
jump into the heavy light chain
combination si let's just take a couple
of minutes to review immunoglobulins
structure most of you are certainly
aware that immunoglobulins are a
heterodimer made up of two heavy chains
and two light chains the antigen-binding
site is encoded by the variable region
to boast the heavy and light chains
we're not going to spend much time
talking about antigen binding today
there are five heavy chain combinations
55 heavy chain isotypes rather IgG IgM B
and E and two light chain isotypes kappa
and lambda giving us a possible 10 heavy
light chain combinations such as i GG
kappa haitch d lambda etc now there i
want to spend a couple of minutes
talking about the traditional tools for
detecting monoclonal proteins in plasma
cell disclosures on the left hand side
you see our serum protein
electrophoresis gel from a patient with
multiple myeloma having a prominent end
spike looking at the gel on the lower
left you can see a distinct band
constituting albumin and then moving
from left to right alpha 1 alpha 2 beta
and gamma regions note that in this
particular aspect gel they distinct and
dense band is formed in the gamma region
instead of the normal heterogeneous
smear you would expect from diverse
immunoglobulin this is because of
monoclonal protein being produced and
gives us the resulting EM spike in the
gamma region that you see on the
densitometry trace up above the gel if
this patient were for instance in igg
lambda multiple myeloma patient
fixation might look something like you
see on the right hand side again from
the left side of the gel you see a total
serum protein band with a very distinct
band in the gamma region following over
stains for igg and lambda denote this
patient has an IgG lambda monoclonal
protein producer about 10 years ago the
FDA approved the free light chain assay
which detects immunoglobulin light
chains that are not bound and intact
immunoglobulin as I mentioned it was FDA
approved in 2001 under the trade name
free light the free light chain assay
detects all light chain only myeloma
patients at diagnosis in contrast to the
fifty percent of light chain only
myeloma patients that are detectable by
SBE it also detects approximately ninety
percent of intact immunoglobulin myeloma
patients at diagnosis owing to the fact
that they produce excess free light
chains as do most plasma cells when it
comes to monitoring patients this short
half-life of the analyte measured by the
free light assay allows a real time
assessment of tumor killed during
therapy we'll discuss a little bit more
about pre light or free light chains and
their short half-life as we go through
the talk the free light assay was
incorporated into the international
myeloma working group guidelines in 2006
and was also incorporated into the
National Comprehensive Cancer Network
guidelines in 2010 now these three
assays when combined together provide a
very powerful tool for the laboratory
and the pathologist in terms of
detecting monoclonal proteins but like
all serum assays they have certain
limitations for serum protein
electrophoresis we know that not all
monoclonal bands migrate in the Gamma
region we know that this can make them
difficult to quantitate at low levels or
when the bands migrate unusually for
amino fixation electrophoresis bands may
be easy to discern as I showed you in
the previous gel if they don't all look
like that
because of this sometimes it's hard to
call the presence of a band especially
when proteins are present at low levels
even if the proteins are readily
distinct we know that amino fixation is
not a quantitative assay it can tell the
pathologist that the patient is making
monoclonal protein and what the isotype
of that protein is but it can't tell
anybody how much and therefore it can't
give us any information about tumor load
during patient during therapy the free
light ass a while detecting all light
chain myeloma patients at diagnosis and
detecting over ninety percent of intact
IG my limitations does in fact not
detect changes in about ten percent of
intact immunoglobulin patients because
they don't make excess light chains so
what I wanted to talk about specifically
today was the heavy chain like chain
combination assayed known as heavy light
heavy light works on the premise that we
know going in that the free light chain
assay provide sensitive detection of
tumor-derived M protein we know that the
ratio between the involved and the
uninvolved light chains provides
evidence of clone allottee in a patient
with monoclonal gammopathy for instance
in a patient with a kappa myeloma we
know whether it's an IgG cat intact
kappa or precap of myeloma we know that
not only the concentration of the Kappa
protein is important but the uninvolved
lambda chain also adds meaning when it
comes to determining clonality the heavy
light assay sought to answer the
question could an assay which detected
individual immunity lobule and heavy
chain light chain pairs provide similar
advantages when in measuring and taft
and protein so we're actually very
excited about the prospects for have you
like the assay was just FDA approved
this past December and what I wanted to
talk about was what these antibodies
specifically are heavy light recognizes
conformational epitopes between heavy
chain and light chains when those two
Chainz combine to form an intact
immunoglobulin their physical space
makes
present conformational determinants
which can be recognized specifically by
heavy light at antibodies these
antibodies recognize epitopes that are
unique to each heavy light chain pair
thus they can distinguish iga kappa from
iga lambda i GG kappa for my GG lambda
and IgM kappa for my GM lambda assays
which will distinguish IgD and i ge are
still in development one of the
questions that comes up is well then
heavy light is simply a replacement for
free light and I'll show you some data
to indicate later that's definitely not
the case because these antibodies
recognize different things as I
mentioned heavy light recognizes
epitopes that are formed when heavy
chains in light chains pair free light
on the other hand recognizes
immunoglobulin light chains that are not
bound in intact immunoglobulin the
epitopes recognized by the free lightly
aging are not available for binding when
bound to heavy chain and thus only
recognize free circulating light chains
now if you're going to make it a say
that measures individual immunity live
eel and heavy chain light chain pairs
then you needed rest assured that when
you sum up the individual pairs for any
given heavy chain isotype that those
will equal the results you get when you
measure total igg for instance so in
this slide which you see is i GG and iga
on the top half of the slide and total
IgM on the bottom half of the slide all
of those are represented on the x-axis
on the y-axis for each graph you see the
sum of any individual heavy chain light
chain pair for instance in the upper
left you see I the sum of IgG lambda and
I GG kappa represented on the y-axis
measured against total igg the lines of
identity for each heavy chain isotype go
running through the graphs let us know
that when we're measuring by heavy light
i GG kappa + igg lambda for instance we
are in fact capturing all of the IgG
normal ranges have been established for
heavy light reagents and I'm not going
to go through each one of these
individually as they are present in the
package inserts but i do want to point
out that light free light one of the
tools that we make use of when using
heavy light is the ratio between
individual heavy chain light chain pairs
down the right-hand side of the table
you can see the normal ratios for each
isotype the ratio for g kappa / g lambda
runs from approximately 1 2 3 as it does
for IGM kappa / lambda for iga kappa /
lambda the ratio is the look for the
normal range is from slightly under 12
just under 2 now i want to point out is
will become evident later when we look
at a case study that changes in the
heavy light chain ratio are the result
of changes in either the concentration
of the involved heavy chain by chain
pair or the uninvolved what heavy chain
why Jane pair so for instance in a
patient with an a cap of myeloma you
might see an increase in the kappa a
kappa / a lambda ratio because the a
lambda was decreased and i'll show you
an example of that as we move forward
one of the things that i want to
emphasize as we go through this today is
that unlike spe and ife both free light
and heavy light read within a normal
range that is to say that everybody
listening to the broadcast today would
have a free kappa and a free lambda
value that can be read hopefully within
the normal range and the same is true
for heavy light for igg A&M because we
can read normal this means that we can
sensitively read abnormal and that
becomes important when we want to talk
about patients who might be being
treated and are entering into remission
we want to measure all the way down into
the normal range similarly it can tell
us about residual disease and it can
also tell us about early relapse
so let's talk for a minute about factors
which can affect monoclonal protein
measurement one of these especially when
it comes to measuring idg is the
variable half-life of immunoglobulins as
you can see from this table looking at
iga an IgM you can see that they have a
half life which is relatively similar to
most normal serum proteins of around six
to eight days interestingly free Kaplan
free lambda provide a monitoring
advantage when measuring free light
chains because the half-life of the
analyte either the free Kapler the free
lambda light chain has a very short
half-life of only two to six hours
however igg has a half-life of almost
three weeks and this can compound
measuring especially when we're talking
about igg myelomas the reason for this
extended half-life of IgG has to do with
a natural natural occurring receptor
known as FC RM some of you may know that
F crm it's the receptor it's scrn
standing firm that's the receptor on
neonatal tissue or neonatal placental
interface tissue this receptor
specifically binds idg and is the
receptor which is responsible for
transferring igg across the maternal
feel interface of the placenta thus
conferring passive immunity to defeat it
to the fetus during gestation well all
proteins are brought taken up by
endothelial cells to be degraded and
into peptides and amino acids and this
is true too for circulating igg however
once it's in the endosome we're actually
on the surface of the endothelial cell
igg binds the FC RN receptor and that
changes its intracellular trafficking
instead of being combined with the
lysozyme a lysosome rather and degraded
proteolytically fcr n-bound igg is
protected from proteolytic degradation
and its traffic back to the cell surface
where it's released into the circulation
the result of this is an extended
half-life for igg due to the fact that
it's protected from proteolytic cleavage
this process however is
concentration-dependent at normal
concentrations of IDG around 10 to 15
grams per liter the half-light the FC RN
receptor is fully saturated this ends up
giving us a half-life for igg of
approximately 21 days as you can see on
this graph however in this data which
was generated as you can see quite some
time ago by Herman Waldman and Sam
strober using radio labeled igg injected
into patients the study that we can't
possibly imagine doing today you can see
that at high concentrations of IDG
around say 60 grams per liter that
saturation of the scrn receptor has made
a lot of this protein no longer
protected from proteolytic degradation
therefore the half-life drops down to
about 10 days similarly if you look at
the other end of the curve you can see
that at very low concentrations of igg
that the half-life can be extended out
dramatically out to 60 or 70 days so in
about 2 grams per liter for instance for
igg that half-life is extended
dramatically because there's plenty of
FC RN receptor available for binding
this actually gives us some insight into
two questions that frequently show up
during a laboratory detection of
monoclonal proteins the first is okay
let's see if I can get the first is
sorry the little technical problem has
been asked on occasion well if the
half-life of igg is three weeks then how
does my patient with 60 grams per litre
of monoclonal protein drop down to 10
grams per liter after a single therapy
cycle if therapy cycle is three weeks to
a month and you have a protein with a
half-life of 21 days it shouldn't get
that dramatic a drop but as you see from
this graph
at 60 grams per liter of monoclonal
protein the half-life is down to 10 days
so until it drops back down into more
physiologic concentrations the half-life
of the protein is much shorter and you
can get much more dramatic drops at the
other end of the scale comes the answer
to the question of if free light is more
sensitive than ife which it is then why
does ife remain positive when the free
light chain test becomes negative well
again you can imagine for a patient with
a monocle and allege EG protein that
would move as a single
electrophoretically on an IFV gel that a
low level of that protein would be
relatively easily detected on in IFE gel
because this protein is president low
concentrations it's continually
protected by the FC RN receptor and yet
it shows up as a band because it is a
single electrophoretically another thing
that we know happens in multiple myeloma
patients for instance that affects their
measurement of monoclonal protein is
that there are changes in plasma plasma
volume in am adequate patients with
compromised renal function can have
dramatic increase in plasma volume
patients who are under disease
exacerbations may have changed it may
have anemia resulting from plasma cell
occupying that space in the bone marrow
well if you've got a test such as SPE or
total immunoglobulin there are
concentration-dependent measurements you
can see how an increase in plasma volume
or decrease in hematocrit to change the
relative concentration of such a protein
but if you're dealing with a ratio
between a monoclonal protein and its
uninvolved isotype partner you could see
as represented on this slide that if you
for instance had a concentration or a
ratio of IgG capita I jeje lambda of
three two one that that concentration
that ratio would remain independent of
both plasma volume and hematocrit
so just to sum up monoclonal protein
measurements can be affected by
catabolism of the IgG of the
immunoglobulin in the case of IgG or
changes in plasma volume in the case of
all three isotypes gim these changes in
monoclonal measurements can in fact
result in them on an underestimation of
the product of production of protein by
the tumor total igg measurements and spe
for instance which are dependent on
concentration cannot account for these
changes and their values will be
affected by the relative concentration
of our relative amount of plasma and cim
adequate in these patients okay let's
talk about the use of heavy light at
diagnosis now one of the things that we
commented on earlier was that not all
monoclonal proteins migrated
appropriately on an S tab and some of
the data to back up that statement other
than your personal experience in the
laboratory is is this data published by
Wang at all about six years ago they
looked at a variety of em proteins and
then categorized them by type and where
they migrated the type of em protein is
listed down the left-hand side of the
table as you can see most of the IgG and
proteins actually migrated appropriately
only six percent migrated not in the
Gamma region for IgA however you can see
that in this particular study
fifty-eight percent of the over 400
patients tested migrated outside the
Gamma region primarily in the beta
region of an aspect where their
concentration might be obscured by
proteins such as transparent you'll also
notice that the bottom of the slide that
free kappa and free lambda also have a
marked tendency to migrate outside the
gamma region this combined with their
relatively lower concentration compared
to the intact immune a lot in proteins
could easily be the reason why only
about fifty percent of light chain only
myeloma patients are detectable by an
SPE
on this particular slide you see an S
Pat gel analysis of 14 IG a myeloma
patients at presentation down the
left-hand side of the gel you see normal
human serum with a dense band ed albumin
available invisible bands of alpha 1
alpha 2 and data and a heterogeneous
smear of diverse immunoglobulin in
normal serum during the gamma region the
other 14 lanes of the gel our samples
taken from known IgA myeloma patients as
you see with the patient for instance on
the right hand side marked by the red
arrow that's a patient where we can
imagine that the monoclonal band is in
fact migrating more or less within the
gamma region but as you look across the
rest of the gel in the cases where bands
are apparent you can see that many of
them migrate outside the gamma region if
you for instance look in on the fourth
lane from the right you'll see that
there's a very dense band on this IgA
myeloma patient but it's migrating
exactly in the beta region where it's
total concentration would be obscured by
the President of endogenous transparent
if you now look at the pace the three
patients in the middle labeled one two
and three I've circled the gamma region
on an S PAP where there's really no
visible band there to be had these
patients do have an IgA myeloma but
judging from their sbes you'd have a
difficult time making that call however
when we plot these patients along with
others on the heavy light acid we see
several interesting things this is data
from a total of thirty-five IgA patients
taken from an MRC trial in the UK and
their IgA kappa is plotted on the x axis
along with their iga lambda value on the
y axis the small blue diamonds in the
middle of the graph denote the normal
range for heavy light iga kappa and
lambda and the two lines that run
through on a diagonal to note the upper
and lower limits of the a capita alien
ratio a couple of things show up first
of all you see that patients one two and
three that were not visible on the
earlier SPE are now readily
distinguishable from normal using their
heavy light concentration so as you can
see patients one and three are IgA kappa
patients impatient too is an iga lambda
patient now one of the things in the
early days of heavy light that we got
from some investigators was well for IgA
I'll just monitor their total IgA
concentration after all it's all the iga
they're making for most of these
patients well the up the normal range
for total iga is representing the box in
the upper right of the graph and as you
can see looking for patients one two and
three if you total there a kappa plus a
lambda the values that are listed
underneath the symbol you can see that
for patients one and three they fit
completely within the iga normal range
patient number two is about three
percent above the normal range how so if
you were measuring by spe all these
patients would look normal if you were
measuring by total iga they would all be
normal or so so small above normal that
he probably wouldn't be able to see this
a distinguish it as being an abnormality
but patient number three as an a cap at
a lambda ratio of 15 with an upper limit
of normal of two patient number one has
an a capita a lambda ratio of 40 again
with an upper limit of 2 patient number
two has an a capita a lambda ratio of
point one five where the normal range
lower limit of the normal range is point
seven eight so as you can see simply
using heavy light all of these patients
were readily distinguishable from normal
when they would not have been by using
SPE or total immunoglobulin
this is just further data using a larger
patient cohort from the French ifm 2005
trial this retrospective study looked at
a total of ninety four IgA patients all
of whom were readily distinguishable
from normal either by their
concentration of involved immunoglobulin
heavy light chain pair or their a
capital ale and a ratio or in most cases
both similar data from the same trial
looking at 225 IDG patients again shows
that these patients are all
distinguishable from normal in the words
of the authors a hundred percent of the
patients were distinguishable from
normal using the heavy light assay I
think if you look closely at the three
open circles just above the normal range
ratio for the IgG lambda patients and
the two or three circles very close just
below the normal range for the I GG
kappa patients you might have trouble
distinguishing those from normal but
ninety-seven percent or more of these
patients were readily distinguishable
from normal using heavy light so let's
talk now about monitoring response to
therapy one of the things that we have
to deal with when using SPE as a
monitoring tool is that if we have
successful therapy and a patient is
approaching normal we know that at low
concentrations of monoclonal protein s
pep has a higher cv than it does with
higher concentrations this was
demonstrated by Jerry Katzman and
co-workers at the Mayo Clinic in an
article published about three years ago
as you see from this data below 10 grams
per liter which is approaching normal
for igg but still markedly abnormal for
IgA or IGM you can see that the Seavey's
in terms of cereal measurements on these
patients now approach twenty to
twenty-five percent giving us a wide
variance in the results that we might be
getting from a patient at any one time
let's look now at a couple of case
studies in this case we'll look at
serial analysis of a patient with an IgG
lambda myeloma the
monitored over time during therapy using
total igg in the blue diamonds
monoclonal igg in the brown circles as
measured off densitometry traces from
the spe and in pink the pink squares the
heavy light chain ratio now for the
purposes of this graph the heavy chat
light chain ratio has been flipped and
what's being plotted is G lambda / g
kappa something that we would normally
not do but it makes it fit on the graph
in this case the s pap gel that is
giving us the monoclonal igg
measurements is represented across the
bottom of the slide what you see here is
that beginning at diagnosis we have a
patient with a total igg concentration
slightly outside the normal range with a
monoclonal spike of about 15 to 20 grams
per liter and with a heavy light chain
gcap g lambda / g kappa ratio of about
10 as the patient is being treated all
three analytes decrease along the same
time frame because they measure variants
of the same analyte monoclonal igg
however when you reach around a 200 a
couple of things that started to happen
one is that the total igg has gone into
the normal range and remains relatively
flat for the next year and a half about
day 350 it's the last time we can see a
band on SPE and therefore get a
monoclonal igg reading off of the
densitometry trace we then area we then
enter a gray area represented on the
graph in which both the ife and the S
pepper red is not abnormal by the
pathologist but we can see following
heavy light that we can actually follow
the patient down into just above just
below the upper limit of normal 4G
lambda / g kappa the patient then stayed
there for the subsequent two
measurements and then probably around a
600 we see the beginning of relapse in a
slight rise in this ratio by day 7 50 or
so
we're now seeing the positive heavy
light chain ratio the S step is finally
caught up and is able to give us some
value but what happened here is for a
period of almost a year we've got no
useful information out of total igg
immuno fixation or SPE because of the
limits of detection or the analyte they
were looking at however during this time
for three measurements we had confidence
if the patient was actually within the
normal range because we could measure
the IgG landover i GG kappa ratio at the
fourth point we start to see what turned
into be the beginning of relapse this is
confirmed a little bit more by this data
that was published last year by Heinz
Ludwig and co-workers this is a patient
with an IgG and IgM excuse me and if you
look on the left-hand side and the upper
the upper part of the figure you see the
S PAP traces as we go across from left
to right of measuring a patient over
time in the middle you see the gels from
the immuno fixation and below that you
see the heavy light chain results now
when you're looking at heavy light
results we've color-coded this so that
red is abnormal and black is normal just
to make it a little easier to follow
when the patient presented we see a
prominent EM spike we see a distinct
band that calls the patient IgA kappa on
the ife and we can see that is a cap of
concentration is about 45 grams per
liter and as a lambda concentration is
point one grams per liter giving us a
ratio of 420 at the next measurement
following the initiation of treatment we
can see that the patient has started to
successfully respond to therapy there's
a smaller spike there's still an eight
and a kappa band on ife that hasn't
really changed because we can't
quantitate off ife but we see by looking
at the heavy light results that the a
kappa concentration has been cut almost
in half down to 25 grams per liter
and that the a lambda concentration is
actually doubled in his patient the
result of that is that the ratio has now
dropped by fourfold to 110 the following
patient visit the Estep was normal or
not abnormal the immuno fixation was
negative but we still sit and we see
that the a kappa and lambda
concentrations yield a normal ratio of
1.36 the concentrations are still
abnormal they're below normal for this
patient probably due to the toxicity of
the therapy just wiping out both the
involved and the uninvolved plasma cells
the following visit yes Stefan ife
continue to yield no results the heavy
light results have returned within the
normal range although they're just
barely over the threshold of the lower
limit of the normal range the ratio is
solidly within the normal range at one
point for indicating that although the
patient has a low a lower level of
plasma cells overall for IgA he clearly
has maintained a normal ratio the
interesting part comes within the next
gel or the next patient visit where the
effect on the ife continue to yield no
data the iga kappa concentration for
this patient the original monoclonal
protein is within normal limits however
you can see that the a lambda
concentration is dropped just below the
normal range giving us a ratio of three
a capita a lambda remembering that the
upper limit of normal is 1.78 we now see
that this patient may be in the first
stages of relapse not represented by the
presence of its monoclonal pret of a
large amount of its monoclonal protein
but by the fact that the a kappa tumor
is now pushing out the uninvolved a
lambda plasma cells giving us a low a
lower level of a lambda and therefore a
higher ratio by the following visit
there's a modest spike on spe and the
ife has returned to yielding a result
being called a kappa but this and you
can see that the heavy light ratio has
gotten worse
and me both immunoglobulins the involved
and the uninvolved have gone outside the
normal range however the important here
is that there was a five and a half
month lapse between the time heavy light
began to give us the first indication to
relapse and I Fe caught up now in the
last visit you can see that the patient
has in fact started to progress into
even worse disease and the heavy light
ratio has actually gone up to nearly
8,000 I want to turn now to a study that
was presented at last year's ash meeting
just this past December this study you
using data and presented by Ola language
group at the NCI looked at a group of 50
patients 38 multiple myeloma and
actually 12 smoldering myeloma patients
who are being treated with a car fills
emit Revlimid low-dose dexamethasone
therapy in this study 33 of these
patients achieved some form of a
complete response 22 reaching the
criteria for a stringent complete
response and eight reaching a near
complete response what language and
co-workers chose to do was measure the
number of crd cycles that had to be
administered to achieve the first CR of
any kind in 15 of these patients and the
first CR was achieved within the first
four cycles of therapy in 12 of the
patients it was between cycles five and
eight and in six of the patients more
than eight cycles of therapy were
required 17 patients failed to reach a
Chiva CR at any time when looking at the
relationship between normalization of
free light and heavy light chain ratios
and as times that it took to get the
patient to see our yutani noticed and
rather interesting association as you
see at the bottom of the of the graph of
the patients that entered CR within the
first four cycles of therapy 13 out of
15 of those patients normalize their
free light chain ratio
after a single cycle of therapy if the
patient's free light chain ratio
normalized represented in red after more
than one cycle therapy it in general
took those patients longer to achieve to
achieve CR similar data was generated
using the heavy light antibody now in
this case we needed to look at after two
cycles of therapy and just remember that
heavy light measures an analyte with a
much longer half-life of days two weeks
then the short half-life of hours of the
free light reagents what you see here
again represented in blue are those
patients who achieved a normalization of
their heavy light chain ratio after two
cycles of therapy and you can see that
all of those patients normalize or
achieve CR within the first eight cycles
of therapy most of them within the first
four cycles of therapy patients
represented in red who achieved who did
not normalize their heavy light ratio
until after two cycles of therapy took
longer in general to achieve CR now one
of the questions that comes up is well
we have a lot of tools for measuring in
a laboratory do we really need to use
all of them I mean after all laboratory
testing is expensive and health care is
under constant scrutiny for trying to
find ways to lower costs well in the
case of multiple myeloma we know that
the drugs that we use cause the tumor to
evolved but first of all and I'm sorry I
got a little ahead of myself there I
want to come back to the point I made
about does free light replace heavy
light load is heavy light replaced free
light and the answer is no they measure
different things now as I told you free
light measures free kappa and free
lambda light chains not associated
intact immunoglobulin whereas heavy
light measures intact heavy chain light
chain pairs this data that came out of
the french ifm study looking at 160 for
patients with an igg kappa myeloma
plots their heavy light i GG kappa
values across the x-axis and their free
light chain kappa values across the Y
and as you can see for any indifferent
as this group of patients there's really
no association between the amount of
heavy light chain being produced the
amount of intact em protein being
produced and the amount of free cap and
free lambda both are biomarkers being
made by the tumor but the levels do not
relate to each other so this is the data
I was alluding to this and the next
slide of the data I was alluding to when
I talk about clonal evolution this is
data published by Keith's at all in the
group from Mayo Scottsdale about a year
and a half ago now looking at how
patients responded to therapy what's
represented on this slide is the result
of a large analysis done on each
individual patient looking at their
tumor subpopulations these
subpopulations were defined using flow
cytometry fluorescence in situ
hybridization pcr and a variety of other
tools what you see out of this
represented in colors as a pie chart is
it for instance if you begin at the nine
o'clock position on this graph you can
see that about three-quarters of the
tumor load for this patient was
represented by the clone designated 1.1
however there were certainly at least
three other noted and distinguishable
subclones within this patient that had a
different profile when using these
multiple tools as the patient was put on
lenalidomide and dexamethasone we can
see that in the first remission that the
level of the clone 1.1 represented in
red had dropped somewhat an expansion of
clone 1.2 represented an orange had
tripled the patient was maintained on
the lend X regimen but went into relapse
at which time there was a marked
increase in the percentage of clone 2.1
represented in green
the patient was then switched to a car
fills amid therapy and you can see that
clung to point one appears to respond to
car fills a myth but clone 1.2 now
becomes a much larger percentage of the
population this trend continues until
the patient finally dissolved into a
plasma cell leukemia where the bulk of
the tumor load was now what had been a
relatively minor subclone of these for
this patient what this is pointing out
is that as we continue to treat tumors
with different regimens that different
populations may be sensitive or
insensitive to the tumor to the
chemotherapy that's being used and that
any single tool may give us a false
sense when it comes to how the patient
is responding this was also looked at
using slim lot more conventional tools
or more traditional tools by Samaritan
coworkers at Memorial sloan-kettering
this looks at a group of patients who
are all treated with the same kind of
therapy and as you can see from this
graph about half of the patients of the
126 cohort achieved the CR during
therapy and about half did not looking
at the type of em protein president
diagnosis using the free light assay and
spe we can see that there that the two
populations were relatively the same at
diagnosis that is about twenty percent
of the patients presented as light chain
and only myeloma patients measurable by
free light about sixty to seventy
percent of the patients represented a
mix of em proteins such as represented
in red here this has been meaning they
were positive for both the spe and free
light assays because they were making
both intact a minute live you learn and
free light chains and represented in
green about ten percent of the patients
they'd intact immunoglobulin only and
had no detectable abnormalities using
the free light test so you can see going
in that we already have a diversity of
patients who are measurable either by
spe or free light alone
or both however when these patients
relapsed which they all did
unfortunately we can see that the
pattern starts to change one is so the
patients who started with free light
only all relapses light chain only
patients measurable by free life the
patients who went in with a mix of em
protein production came out with an even
bigger mix as you see for the patients
who achieve CR on the left almost half
the patients in this group down
regulated their free light chain
production and we're only and we're
measurable by spe making intact
immunoglobulin however as you can see
about eleven percent of these patients
converted to a phenotype where they were
only making free light chains
represented in blue for the patients who
achieve something less than a CR upon
initial therapy you can see that in fact
about twenty five percent of those
patients stopped making excess light
chains as measurable by free light but
thirty eight percent of the patients now
made light chain only the patients who
started measuring who started with an
intact immunoglobulin only production
came out for the most part continuing to
make immunoglobulin intact
immunoglobulin only but as you can see
seventeen percent in both groups now
started making excess free light chains
as well so there's something to be said
in here this something that's being told
to us about plasma cell biology and
responses to chemotherapy we're not
quite sure what this means yet but
what's also clear from this is if we're
only using a single tool such as either
spe or free light or immuno fixation
we're going to miss patients either at
diagnosis or at relapse or both now I
want to add right now that Hani how soon
who was the principal investigator on
this study at sloan-kettering is
currently looking at the same patient
cohort using the heavy light assay as a
replacement for spe in this particular
group of patients especially in the
relapse group and we're very excited
about the prospects
that might come out of that study okay
so then the question becomes well you've
got these tests now in addition to SPE
and ife we've got heavy light entry like
how do I put all this together now this
is not an algorithm that has been
publishing a guideline at this point it
is however a suggestion of a potential
algorithm for testing myeloma patients
if you have a patient with a suspected
monoclonal gammopathy we know that data
published by Jerry Katzman and
co-workers at the Mayo Clinic has
indicated that the combination of ste
and free light chain will detect all
monoclonal gammopathy patients all
symptomatic monoclonal gammopathy
patients at diagnosis that if the
patient with a suspected monoclonal
gammopathy due to the symptoms has an
unremarkable aspect and a normal free
light chain ratio if that patient does
not have a monoclonal protein disease
and can be evaluated for other causes if
however either one of those tests
results in an abnormality then we need
to reflex to an IFV in order to identify
the isotype this is primarily for
efficiency as it will let us run in one
test and determine what the isotype is
of the monoclonal protein being produced
at that point we can now use heavy light
to establish a baseline for the
appropriate heavy light chain pair so we
don't need to run all three we can
simply run a cap and a lambda fur and
ife that says the patient is a capital
or a lambda or igg4 an IgG patient etc
that lets us now monitor disease in
response to therapy using the
combination of SPE heavy light and free
light so i hope what I've been able to
convey today is that heavy light
recognizes unique conformational
epitopes which can distinguish between
heavy chain light chain pairs that this
enables the clinician in the laboratory
to quantitate involved and uninvolved
intact immunoglobulin in myeloma and
related plasma cell dis gracious that
the heavy light chain ratio can quantify
disease by measuring involved against
uninvolved immunity
in ways in which total email avianna
isotype measurements cannot and that the
heavy light ratio can be measured at
levels below the detectable range for
either SPE or ife again heavy light like
free light can read all the way into the
normal range and therefore gives a
sensitive detection for patients who are
either entering remission have minimal
residual disease or are in the early
stages of relapse data that I didn't
have time to show you today but using
heavy like we've indicated that like the
free light ratio combining heavy light
with other staging criteria can enhance
risk stratification in newly diagnosed
patients and with that I would just
remind you that we have some time to
take a few questions there is the Q&A
button in the lower left section of your
screen and I'm now going to turn it back
over to our moderator so that we can
start to address any questions that
might have come in thank you Richard for
that very interesting webinar audience
the session is now open for questions
you may ask a question by typing the
question into the question and answer
box and the located in the lower left
hand of your screen the first question I
have is does heavy light and free
lightning we don't need to do mrd
testing EG via flow cytometry well
that's actually an interesting question
and I don't think that's going to be the
way that this shakes out we won't know
until groups such as the International
myeloma working group have put together
guidelines but I think what's more
likely to be is that heavy light and
free light may give us sort of a gateway
into which test patients should be
evaluated for Mr D I think it's easy to
see that if a patient for instance since
we know that free light and heavy light
are going to be cheaper ways to test for
this patient for whether or not they
have minimal residual disease that if we
use free light and heavy light
as the gateway by running those tests
ahead of time if the both of those tests
are normal that's a candidate for
looking at flow cytometry which is very
sensitive obviously but if those tests
either one of those tests is abnormal I
think it's fairly safe to say at that
point that that patient would not be a
candidate for flow cytometry evaluation
of mr d they're just not there yet the
next question I'm sorry I'm Jim just
opening this up does this test provide a
measurement of em spike ie myeloma
protein yes it absolutely does we can
measure what the heavy light result you
would get let's say a patient is an IgG
kappa patient there's two there's three
pieces of data that will come out of
there if you may use heavy light igg
reagents on a patient with a g kappa
myeloma you'll get a measurement of the
EM spike in the sense that you'll get an
IgG kappa concentration from that
patient and that you can compare against
the normal range you'll also get a
measure of the uninvolved igg lambda
concentration and we know for instance
that in patients with g kappa myeloma
that their g lambda plasma cells are
suppressed in the bone marrow by the
tumor the third piece of information is
you'll get is the ratio between g kappa
and g lambda so you'll be able to
compare not only the size of the spike
using g kappa but the uninvolved g
lambda concentration and the overall
clone allottee of the patient by taking
the ratio g kappa 2g lambda
thank you you displayed reference
intervals with a 2d graph can the
reference intervals be adequately
documented with a single numerical range
for each analyte well I think the answer
you know comes not only from the fact
that that we've done a fair amount of
testing in a variety of normal
populations and they all fall within
that that normal range so you know
understand that that the graph that we
displayed that have reference interval
not only had the ratio between any
particular analytes kappa and lambda but
it also had the concentration of each so
in reality there's three normal ranges
if i display it on the graph like that
because for each data point there's a
concentration of for instance a kappa
and a lambda these were all the normal
ranges that we put into the FDA
submission they had been looked at by
several different investigators I should
comment at this point that heavy light
has actually been FDA approved in Europe
for over a year and has been widely used
especially by the French group and so I
think we're pretty confident about the
normal ranges that we have clearly the
FDA bought into it which is always
important
thank you the next question is from
Zhang Xiao a clinical chemistry fellow
from Houston Methodist Hospital two
questions the first question could this
heavy light as they diagnose heavy chain
disease the second one is he let such he
wants to know if he can have your slides
and this will be posted online for a
while so I can answer that one so it's
actually an interesting question and I
would say right now the answer is as
best we understand it probably would not
work very well on heavy chain disease
and that is because the reagent
recognizes combination epitopes of heavy
and light chains this is not every agent
that recognizes igg it recognizes i GG
kappa specifically so it recognizes
conformational epitopes form between the
pairing of g kappa and g lambda thank
you the next question are there any
efforts at this time to incorporate the
heavy light assay into the international
guidelines for myeloma response so
that's a great question the answer is
yeah we're absolutely working on it
binding site has a history of working
very closely with the international
myeloma working group many of the
members of this group are
enthusiastically looking at heavy light
in clinical studies right now that many
of which we hope will be published this
year and I know that they are now
looking at whether or not this should be
incorporated into a revision of the
guidelines for diagnosing and monitoring
plasma cell disclosures
our next question could heavyweight
replace ife i'm going to say the answer
to that really is yes and no and and the
way i would suggest it that it be used
is you probably aren't going to want to
run heavy like right up front when you
know simply from say let's let's say you
ran spe and free life to diagnose
whether or not you had a patient with a
monoclonal gammopathy if you get a spike
on it on an S pep or an abnormal free
light ratio or concentration you still
don't know what the isotype of that
intact pair whether or not it's an
intact IG pair and whether or not and
what the isotype of that pair might be
so what we'd suggest at that point is
that you run a single amino fixation at
diagnosis in order to determine the
isotype of the monoclonal protein that
you're dealing with now while I'd love
to tell you and my marketing department
will be more than happy to say that well
if you ran all six that would be great
because you get the same information the
reality is that's not particularly
efficient so if you run a single ife it
diagnosis to determine the isotype of
lee patient you'll be able to tell for
instance if it's a light chain only
myeloma then you don't want to run heavy
light but you certainly want to run free
light but if the patient the gel then
comes back and says well it's a g kappa
myeloma then you know that if you run g
kappa and g lambda heavy light you get
the information you need what we know
right now is that it doesn't appear that
there's a lot of data to be had by
looking at the other isotypes so for
instance looking at A&M in an IgG
patient by heavy light is not
particularly useful but using the jeek
the heavy light g kappa g luanda testing
provides very valuable information
you Richard I just have some little
information the slides are available for
downloading on your screen by clicking
on content and files the PDF is there we
still have a couple more questions that
I do want to address as well and the
next question as per your suggested
myeloma algorithm does this mean that
urine is no longer necessary or are
there selected cases where urine would
be necessary so this is sort of an
ongoing discussion the reality of the
situation is has been published for
quite some time now that what we measure
in urine can be measured in serum so for
instance when we talk about free light
we know that patients who have that if
you have for instance free light chains
in your urine and therefore resulting
positive test for bens Jones proteinuria
that those light chains started off in
your serum that they were filtered out
by the kidneys and ended up in your
bladder as a result of their initial
production and presence in this serum
there's been data published for quite
some time now where mayo and several
other groups have looked and said that
any patient that spence-jones positive
we can detect using serum-free light so
from that standpoint they don't really
necessarily need urine at diagnosis I do
want to point out however that the
international guidelines say for
multiple myeloma that you don't need
your and it diagnosis in order to
monitor or in order to declare the
patient as having multiple myeloma but
you're in proteinuria is still being
used as a measuring metric for patients
with al or primary amyloidosis so the
answer is it's probably not necessary
because you're going to detect anything
in serum that will eventually end up in
the urine but reality is current
guidelines indicate for amyloidosis that
it's probably true I didn't show you any
data
today on heavy light and amyloidosis
there's actually some very exciting data
that's being put together looking at the
utility of heavy light in al amyloidosis
and hopefully in some future broadcast
we might be able to talk about that just
a couple more questions and the next
question what is the clinical utility
for total light chain measurement short
answer none that I know of I've asked
multiple clinicians who some of whom
still use total light chains why they're
using it and what does it tell them and
the primary answer I get back is
tradition those sites that are using
total light chains there's no indication
there's certainly no guideline published
there's no utility that I've ever been
able to detect that total light chains
give you any information that is not
there in fact if you look at the
relative concentration so if you're
measuring for instance kappa light
chains and if you're measuring total
kappa in a patient with either an IgG
kappa or a light chain a kappa light
chain only myeloma you're not only
measuring the kappa that's associated
with igg you're also measuring the
capital that's associated with IgM with
IgA with IgD with IgE and the free kappa
and there's just such a cloud in there
that is really hard to tell what you're
getting if you look at the concentration
of free kappa versus total it's
literally 500 it's free kappa is present
about five hundred to a thousand fold
less in concentration than total capital
or total lambda so and there's no
guidelines out there anywhere or any
data that i'm really aware of thats a
total kappa of total them to provide any
meaningful measurements in any sort of
plasma syllabus kwasia or monoclonal
protein measuring
thank you the last question is a
two-fold question it is what is the
reimbursement status of heavy light and
where is heavy late available to order
today okay so heavy light is
reimbursable under Medicare and private
insurance it's actually going to be
billed out i think and for those of you
who are used to it as a similar code the
same code that's used for free light in
terms of i don't remember the exact cpt
code but it's nephelometer ii by other
institutes the same cpt code that's used
for free light in terms of where it's
currently available mayo medical
laboratories are running heavy light now
so it will be available as a send out
through any local hospital who sent out
to mail and labcorp we believe will be
live for running heavy light within 30
days if not less I've talked to the
folks at labcorp personally and they're
just finishing up dotting the i's and
crossing the t's on their protocols and
should beginning be beginning to offer
the test as I said within 30 days so
Thank You audience thank you for all
your questions thank you dr. O'Hara
again for this very informative and
educational webinar if you have any
questions regarding anything you learned
on this Web cast would like a route to
request any additional information
please feel free to visit our booth here
at clinical diagnostics and research bio
conference live virtual event just click
on binding site under the exhibit hall
directory you can also contact us by
email at info at the binding site com or
find more information on our website at
www site com thank you